it's game day in america and we've all
had a hell of a year
my wife died of covet 19 and i still
think she was making a little too much
of it
my son left to join a militia and though
i'll miss him
i'm proud of him our greatest strength
as a country is unity
no matter how sick you are or how you
feel or what's being done to you
you unite and if my wife was here today
she would tell you the same thing
wouldn't you honey
you don't yell at your elected
representatives in the street they love
you
don't leave your house stop trying to
trade stocks it's not
fun yeah maybe i lost all my money on
gamestop stock
and i haven't worked in nine months but
it's [ __ ] game day
and i'm an american that knock right
there that'll be the sheriff evicting me
because i haven't paid a mortgage in 10
months
i said i was moving out tomorrow so just
go out there
and buy a [ __ ] jeep you're driving
around an empty parking lot of a school
at night
and you if you need to you yell
things that you can't say on social
media for your own good
point now it's time to get the gun